bienvenue à l'université des maires de
l'Ouest parisien nous allons aborder un
sujet très important pour les communes
celui de la rénovation énergétique des
écoles je crois que c'est une des des
dépenses les plus fortes de des des
villes puisque 30 % de la consommation
des bâtiments euh communaux et les les
écoles demeurent le type de bâtiment le
plus consommateur devant devant les
équipements sportifs et les bâtiments
socio-culturels alors pour parler de de
ce sujet Sylvia bertdupuis bonjour
bonjour vous êtes la première adjointe
au maire de Saint-Germain Ré en charge
notamment de l'éducation mais aussi des
relations internationales et vous êtes
aussi conseillère régional eu
Jean-Baptiste amonique bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le maire de Villepreux et et
puis vous avez été chargé d'un d'un
d'une mission d'un rapport sur la sur la
transition énergétique on en parlera
peut-être à à l'issue de de ce plateau
et puis avec nous Sylvie Meron IFA
bonjour bonjour Alors vous présentez la
société Energis qui est un opérateur de
la transition énergétique absolument
nous nous prenons en charge l'ensemble
des actions liées à la transition
énergétique des bâtiments du territoire
de l'audit énergétique des travaux de
l'installation des panneaux
photovoltaïques et le tout en utilisant
en
trouvant en élaborant de l'ingénierie
financière pour faire que c éléments
soient concrets et sortent de terre
d'accord donc vous aidez évidemment les
communes
notamment alors là on va parler des
écoles c'est vrai que vous occupez aussi
des autres bâtiments mais l'école est un
élément important justement
Jean-Baptiste Monique peut-être qu'on on
peut faire le point oui c'est une des
dépenses les plus importantes pour les
pour les communes oui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les collectivités sont
face à mur il y a le mur de
l'investissement il y a le mur
énergétique et la rénovation la
réhabilitation des bâtiments scolaires
et bien est un enjeu colossal qui est
devant nous je crois qu'il y a deux
chiffres qui sont très parlants c'est
celui de 51000 51000 bâtiments scolaires
on englobe aussi le périscolaire à
rénoveré aujourd'hui en France
l'estimation c'est 52 milliards 52
milliards d'euros pour pouvoir être à la
hauteur de de cette enjeu alors on a eu
quelques annonces dernièrement par le
gouvernement notamment le fait de
pouvoir abonder le F vert de 500
millions d'euros un grand nombre de
d'associations d'élus également se sont
mobilisé pour obtenir une pérénisation
du fond vert alors pour le moment je ne
dirais pas qu'il est pérénisé il a été
reconduit sur les trois prochaines
années et c'est évidemment un soutien à
l'investissement avec d'autres
dispositifs qui existe qui est
nécessaire je vous prends un exemple à
Villepreux aujourd'hui 50 % des mètres
carrés du bâti municipal de la commune
c'est du bâti scolaire c'est ça et et le
bâti scolaire à lui seul 50 % et le bâti
scolaire à lui seul représente 37 % de
nos dépenses énergétiques ce sont des
bâtiments des années 70 80 qui ont
besoin évidemment d'être rénové oui
c'est ça c'est ça le problème c'est que
souvent ENF Sylvi Albert du puit vous
pouvez le confirmer la plupart des
écoles les lycées c'est un peu différent
ils sont plus anciens mais la plupart
des écoles c'est les années 70 80 c'est
des années où on avait pas l'idée de de
de de réduire les dépenses énergétiques
comme on l'a aujourd'hui évidemment
effectivement nos nos écoles nous en
avons 21 éclees publiqu primairire à
Saint-Germain hlay date des années 70 80
en moyenne entre 40 et 50 ans bien
évidemment les problématiques étaient
pas le le même à l'époque il y avait pas
le même nombre d'enfants il y avait pas
les mêmes usages depuis les les choses
on ont changé bien évidemment c'est une
thématique dont la ville s'est saisie
très sérieusement et et qui est mise en
place lors des rénovation de groupes
scolaires on essaie à la ville de
Saint-Germain enlaet de se dire que nous
rénovons un groupe scolaire par mandat
ah oui c'est conséquent rénover un
groupe scolaireou c'est l'argent public
c'est l'argent public et il faut à la
fois je pense pouvoir associer un petit
peu tous les acteurs que vous voyez au
sein d'une école parce que Jean-Baptiste
l' l'a rappelé il y a du scolaire il y a
du
périscolaire ce sont des usages de
bâtiments différents et puis vous avez
ceux qui vivent au quotidien vousz des
élèves vous les avez
d'ailleurs sont présents des
enseignants et il est important de les
écouter mais important aussi de se
rappeler toujours de l'argent public que
les investissements sont très
conséquents et qu'il faut prendre les
bonnes décisions et du moment où vous
prenez la décision et où vraiment le
groupe scolaire est livré vous savez il
y a quand même quelques années
qui sont passées et il faut s'assurer
qu'au moment de la livraison du groupe
scolaire on on aura pris les bonnes
décisions mais c'est quelque chose qui
se met bien en place av vous même la
rénovation d'ailleurs c'est vrai que
dans dans les villes on voit que bah les
éclairages on les baisse un peu on peut
on peut baisser le le le le chauffage
dans les dans les administrations
peut-être dans les écoles c'est plus
compliqué alors je crois que là vous
évoquez un sujet important je pense que
sur ce sujet de la transition
énergétique il faut marcher sur nos deux
jambes c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un volet
de sobriété ouais c'est-à-dire essayer
de consommer moins et c'est ce que nous
avons fait dans l'ensemble des communes
au moment où on était au au plus fort de
la crise énergétique nous avons toutes
et tous conduit des planans de sobriété
l'état aussi également avec un objectif
de réduction de 10 % et bien de la
facture énergétique et effectivement
dans les écoles ça s'est traduit par des
mesures que nous avons dû évidemment
accompagner avec beaucoup de pédagogie
et et d'explication et l'autre volet
c'est celui de l'efficacité et je crois
que c'est ce vers quoi il faut tendre
aujourd'hui désormais c'est ces travaux
qui sont essentiels parce que ce qui est
important et ça a été dit c'est derrière
le bâti il y a le service public il y a
le service public de l'éducation
évidemment avec l'enseignement avec
aussi le le périscolaire et puis il y a
trois objectifs celui évidemment de
réduire la consommation d'énergie celui
éventuellement d'avoir demain des
bâtiments qui soient aussi et bien en
autoconsommation c'est ce que nous
allons faire avec du photovoltaïque avec
des cuves aussi de récupération d'eau
pluviale pour les sanitaires pour
l'éclairage et puis l'autre enjeu c'est
celui d'améliorer le confort de toutes
celles et ceux qui sont dans l'école on
a évoqué les enfants sans oublier les
enseignants et puis les nombreux
personnels et bien des mairies qui
travaillent que ce soit les adsem que ce
soit évidemment les personnels de
restauration nettoyage et cetera avant
d'avoir peut-être des solutions avec
Sylvie mer ilera euh un mot c'est vrai
vous disiez bah faut prendre les bonnes
décisions pour des des choses qui vont
qu'on verra dans quelques années et
c'est vrai que bah les de mondes on
change
euh alors je vais vous donner un un
exemple très concret moi ça fait 9 ans
que je suis élue à l'éducation à la
ville de Saint-Germain en laai et j'ai
bien vu l'évolution des demandes vous
savez on a beaucoup ces temps de
concertation lors des conseils d'école
et j'ai bien vu l'évolution des demandes
des parents d'élèves il y a 9 ans et les
demandes maintenant il y a 9 ans j'ose
dire que on me parle parler de la
dangerosité de la présence d'un arbre
dans une cour de récréation ça vous
parle parce que sur les racines on
risquait de de tomber c'était dangereux
et désormais 9 ans plus tard qu'est-ce
qu'on nous demande des cours des cours
végétalisé de replanter des arbres et
bien sûr on le comprend et on va
accompagner cette démarche parce que
elle est très importante mais à nous
comme ça vient d'être dit de bien savoir
où est le juste équilibre et le bon
investissement des deniers publics d'une
façon générale est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
rénover ou ou construire alors ça ça ça
dépend mais nous on a lancé très tôt
lors de notre arrivée aux
responsabilités en 2020 un audit
patrimonial énergétique de l'ensemble de
nos bâtiments on a une cinquantaine de
bâtiments il y a ceux qui vont être
évidemment concerné par le décret
tertièire et donc on a nos écoles et on
a un gymnase et finalement je vais vous
donner un montant si on devait faire le
minimum syndical entre guillemets sur
les dépenses de rénovation de
réhabilitation sur nos bâtiments it pour
10 millions d'euros euh ce qui
correspond à deux mandats
d'investissement à villepreu
pratiquement donc je rejoins ce qui a
été dit la priorité pour nous c'est les
écoles donc ce sera un plan de 3
millions d'euros on espère peut-être
plus tard et bien avancer sur les autres
bâtiments mais 100 millions d'euros
c'est ce que représente le coût d'une
rénovation à Villepreux et je rappelle
que le fond vert dans les evvelines
cette année c'est-à-dire pour 259
communes peut-être un peu moins
maintenant avec les fusions euh
représentait 17 millions d'euros donc
vous voyez bien quand évoqué les 52
milliards tout à l'heure nécessaires
pour être à la hauteur de cet enjeu ça
veut dire que le compte n'y est pas
encore et c'est pour ça que des acteurs
comme comme vous sont je crois
essentiels pour nous aider à parvenir
nos objectifs juste un mot je passe la
parole tout de suite mais de combien les
les dépenses d'énergie ont augmenté dans
les dans les dans les dernières années
au fond depuis
la c'est plus de 75 % à 100 %
d'augmentation sur gaz électricité un
chiffre 1 million d'euros de dépens de
fonctionn subi en plus sur l'année 2023
avec l'inflation ou en fonction des
consommations consommation en soi Sylvie
mer alors oui justement je voulais
rebondirement oui absolument de toute
façon
effectivement pardon je je mets mieux le
le micro en fonction de ce que ce qui
vient d'être dit on ne va pas pouvoir
rénover tous les bâtiments parce que les
les budgets sont pas du tout prévu pour
ce sujet donc il va falloir arbitrer et
faire ces fameux audit énergétiques dont
dont dont on parlait tout à l'heure un
schéma directeur on a l'habitude de le
faire on fait des schémas directeurs
immobiliers donc on va faire des audits
de tous les bâtiments et on va rajouter
la composante énergétique une fois qu'on
a fait ça on va se réaliser que Ben dans
cet ensemble dans cette cartographie de
bâtiments bah il va y avoir peut-être
comme la loi de Pareto est toujours là
20 % des bâtiments qui sont responsables
de 80 % des consommations consommations
il va falloir s'attaquer à cela de façon
prioritaire dans les écoles dans les les
bâtiments publics et comment dire la
l'intelligence des collectivités et des
gens en au manette c'est de de
finalement arbitrer en disant bah je
vais avec le budget que j'ai pouvoir
adresser des travaux aux bâtiments les
plus énerg voilà les plus énergies
évidemment oui il faut faire il y a des
choix il y a des choix il y a un
arbitrage de toute façon ESS à il y a la
question du retour sur l'investissement
justement et la question du retour sur
investissement des sociétés comme la
nôtre aident les collectivités sur le
financement de ces projets donc sur la
réalisation des travaux bien sûr mais
quand on va faire ces audits on va
établir et
bien les économies d'énergie que va vont
dégager les travaux qu'on va mettre en
œuvre et finalement on va se rémunérer
on va payer les travaux en fonction des
économie d'énergie d'accord aujourd'hui
quelque chose un peu semblable existe ça
s'appelle les contrats de performance
énergétique mais ils sont capés un c un
certain pourcentage d'économie
aujourd'hui nerly met sur en fait met à
la disposition des collectivités des
nouveaux contrats type où on prend en
charge en fonction des travaux qu'on va
identifier on va prendre en charge le
coût des travaux et on voit en fonction
des économies d'énergie ce que la
collectivité va finalement
payer sur des plans de 8 ans en fonction
de ce qu'elle va valoriser en terme
d'économie d'énergie et ça c'est un
système vraiment nouveau qui j'espère va
aider les territoires dans le dans leur
accélération VO les les alors on va
parler des rénovation peut-être et des
constructions c'estàd des des qu'est-ce
qu'on fait quand quand on veut rénover
et quand on fait quand on veut voilà
faire des dépenses d'énergie moindre que
que celles qui sont aujourd'hui nous là
dans le plan donc c'est un plan de de 3
ans on va rénover quatre écoles et on
commence la première phase cette année
avec deux groupes scolaires jean- Rostan
marcury qui sont à eux seul 24 % des
dépenses énergétiqu de de la commune et
donc ça passe par des travaux évidemment
de rénovation intérieur extérieur les
ouvrants les entrants changement de de
chaudière on va également essayer d'être
performant sur ce que je disais sur
l'efficacité l'autoconsommation en
déployant aussi du du panneau
photovoltaïque mais c'est vrai que les
travaux sont sont importants et donc il
faut prioriser et arbitrer ça ça a bien
été dit et peut-être ce que je voudrais
me permettre d'ajouter c'est qu'il y a
les travaux qu'on peut prévoir mais ceux
qui vont être prévus en fonction nos
budgets peut-être à une échéance de 10
ans et qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour un
groupe scolairire qui effectivement est
extrêmement énergivore pendant les 10
ans avant qu'on puisse le rénover et et
nous avons cet exemple à la ville de
Saint-Germain nous avons travaillé avec
le groupe scolaire Schnapper qui est
notre plus gros groupe avec plus de 400
élèves ce qui est très important pour
pour un groupe scolaire et nous avons
monté un groupe de concertation avec les
usagers du quotidien que sont les
enseignants euh et les parents d'élèves
qui portent la voix des enfants même
s'il faut parfois un petit peu pondérer
et nos services et nous regardons et
nous testons des choses parfois très
simples sur
l'ouverture la nuit des des des ouvrants
justement pour voir si le matin au moins
quand on arrive et et ça fonctionne il y
a aussi ce que je voulais rajouter par
rapport à vos propos madame tout à
l'heure c'était aussi de dire vous nous
accompagnez merci beaucoup c'est
formidable mais il y a il y aura aussi
ensuite l'utilisation au quotidien et il
y a besoin de pédagogie il a besoin d'û
est que on peut ouvrir une fenêtre et
que c'est pas dramatique et que si nos
enfants ont un petit peu froid pendant
pendant 10 minutes je dis ça parce que
j'ai beaucoup regarder ce qui se passe à
l'international dans d'autres pays on
apprend beaucoup des expériences aussi
d'autres pays en la matière les usages
Chang on estime à 10 % de consommation
énergétique lié aux usages seulement à
la à l'occupation des à l'occupation on
estime à 10 % donc des choses simples et
répétitives et récurrent pe vraiment
faire la différence justement vous
insistiez sur ce point Jean-Baptiste
Monique l'ASS associer au fond les les
gens qui qui utilisent c'estd peut-être
les parents d'élèves et et les
enseignants à à ses travaux de
rénovation ça vous paraît important
ou dans dans laes dans la mesure du
possible sur ce type de grand projet
d'abord il y a quelque chose qui n'a pas
été dit mais il faut le rappeler la
rénovation énergétique des écoles
est une priorité mais ce ne sont pas les
seuls investissements que les
collectivités doivent réaliser sur un sû
non non donc déjà c'est un des plus
importants c'est un des plus importants
mais c'est la raison pour laquelle je je
suis tout à fait en phase avec ce qui
vient d'être dit il faut aussi que nous
arrivions avec nos partenaires à trouver
un certain nombre de solutions qui
permettent de rendre des bâtiments moins
énergivor dans ce lapse de temps et bien
avant qu'il puissent
bénéficierau plus structurant évidemment
qu'on a c'est comme on parlait de
végétalisation des cours d'école on a
mené un certain nom de projet notamment
avec le soutien de la Région î-de-france
on va poursuivre puisque créer des îlos
de fraîcheur en période aussi de de
fortes canicule dont nous sommes
maintenant très souvent l'objet est
essentiel quand on fait ce type de
projet on va travailler avec le
périscolaire on va travailler avec la
directrice d'école puisque certes tout
le monde maintenant veut des arbres et
des espaces embrager mais il faut aussi
que la cour d'école puisse rester
fonctionnel pour les différents usages
que et bien les enfants peuvent en avoir
c'est pardon oui je je voulais compléter
on a beaucoup parlé de de travaux il y a
aussi tout un volet d'énergie
renouvelable auquel voilà auquel on va
devoir recourir aussi déjà pour quoi par
exemple alors alors le les panneaux
photovoltaïques sont finalement les
systèmes les plus évidents à mettre en
place une centrale photovoltaïque ça
peut rendre une ça peut prendre en
charge 20 à 30 % de des consommations
énergétiques d'un ensemble bâtimentaire
ça permet une certaine autonomie
énergétique et c'est aussi le le sens de
l'histoire de pouvoir justement être
autonome
énergétiquement et pouvoir justement
placer des ces centrales là un peu
partout valoriser des toitures installer
des ombrières sur les parkings et puis
bien sûr pouvoir financer le
tout avec les collectivités pour
accélérer cette cette installation
d'énergie photovoltaïque comment on fait
pour obtenir le financement des nerl
alors bah alors on on on on cofinance
enfin on cofinance pas mais il y a
plusieurs en fait il y a plusieurs il y
a plusieurs il y a plusieurs façons il y
a plusieurs comment dire véhicules
financiers euh la commune peut tout à
fait c'est les communes qui vous
contactent bien sûr les collectivités
peuvent prendre en régie des une
centrale photovoltaïque c'est-à-dire
qu'elle l'achète nous on vient l'aider à
la conception et au conseil et puis
elles peuvent aussi constituer des
sociétés d'économie mixte et là elles
sont dans des contraintes
administratives d'appel d'offres et de
mise en concurrence et puis la troisième
voix une voix qu'on qu'on qu'on qu'on
privilégie qui est une société privée
qu'on va faire avec la collectivité et
qui va permettre en fait quand par
exemple on est en fin de mandat on a 2
ans de mandat et qu'on veut que les
choses soient s'accélèent qu'on doit
mettre les choses de façon rapide et
bien absolument eu on ça ça permet juste
que les collectivités puissent de
manière très agile investir dans une
centrale la construire avec une société
privée et pouvoir bénéficier en fait de
l'électricit qui se fait dans le
département sur la géothermie c'est ça
on va d'ailleurs parler du rapport dans
un instant juste il y a la rénovation il
y a il y a aussi les constructions là on
voit beaucoup le bois qui
réapparaît est-ce que est-ce que y a pas
parfois comme ça des solutions qui
paraissent évidentes et peut-être il
faut réfléchir un peu
plus alors je me permet de répondre en
tant du snmand vous savez on parle
beaucoup du du bois et j'ai vu
l'évolution des constructions au
Normandie énormément évoluer je pense
qu'on doit vraiment se poser la question
je je rebondis sur cette notion de
pérenité du bâtiment ce qu'on est
capable de voir c'est que nous avons
certains établissements scolaires qui
eux ont 100 ans voir plus et et qu'on
pourra peut-être sans doutes qui sont en
pierre rénover peut-être à l'infini les
rénovations elles interviennent tous les
50 ans euh quit de l'avenir de nos
écoles qu'on a pu faire en bois nous on
vient de livrer un groupe scolaire en en
2018 il est tout en bois on a le
département et la région ont livré le
lycée international il y a 2 ans qui est
aussi tout en bois vous voyez que
l'évolution du bâtiment parfois
questionne euh alors ce n'est pas
forcément l'aspect extérieur qui va dire
que l'État vraiment du bâtiment mais on
doit se poser vraiment la question du
traitement avant après il n'y a pas que
l'esthétique encore une fois j'insiste
beaucoup sur la
pérennité l'usage du bâtiment jamais
oublier que dans des écoles on a des
enfants absolument ça paraît bête de dit
comme ça mais il faut y penser et il
faut le rappeler aussi aux architectes
qui nous accompagnent sur de nombreux
projets un mot avant de passer la parole
aux étudiants turspo pendant les émeutes
il y a eu des écoles qui ont été qui ont
été attaqué quel était le le le
sentiment des des élus que vous
êtes moi j'ai j'ai surtout en mémoire
puisque c'est c'est très récent et je
sais pas s'il est là aujourd'hui mais je
voudrais en tout cas avoir évidemment un
mot de solidarité en destination de tous
les élus touchés plus particulièrement
auprès de mon collègue Nicolas d'Inville
oui maire de la verrière
qui éc j'ai pas suivi directement ce ce
dossier là mais j'ai cru comprendre que
il y avait un élan de solidarité
notamment de la part de la région qui
s'estit mis en place bon il y a beaucoup
d'incompréhension un peu de colère je
vous cache pas surtout quand on
s'aperçoit que ces écoles brûlées sont
parfois et bien dans des quartiers qui
bénéficient à des populations justement
qui en ont le plus besoin donc c'est
autant d'investissement à aller
rechercher et donc ce sont des coûts
très très importants pour les
collectivités qui évidemment n'étaient
pas prévu et ni au programme donc ça va
nécessiter des arbitrages et peut-être
qu'un certain nombre de choses devront
être reportées dans le temps pour
pouvoir aller à la priorité c'est-à-dire
à reconstruction un mot sur le rapport
que vous avez fait au la demande de
daniè panierach qui est ministre de la
transition écologique vous étiez en
charge de la Commission sur la
production de chaleur et d'autres
énergies bac carbone et l'une des
recommandations c'est au fond vous dites
il faut accélérer sur toutes les
énergies renouvelables alors oui
c'est-à-dire que il faut partir d'un
constat simple c'est que nous n'allons
pas sortir du nucléaire du jour au
lendemain et que au contraire il faut
continuer dans cette voielà tout tout en
déployant l'ensemble des autres énergies
renouvelables possibles dans cette
mission qui a été confiée par la même le
solaire dont on dit oui alors après on
parlait tout à l'heure du bois si on
parle de la biomasse la biomasse on sait
que c'est une ressource qui n'est pas
inépuisable c'est-à-dire qu'il va
falloir quantifier hiérarchiser
prioriser en fonction des usages et en
fonction on va dire des secteurs vers
quel secteur est-ce qu'on FL flèche en
priorité ce type d'énergie en tout cas
parce qu'on aura pas le temps de de de
rentrer làdedans juste dire que des PR
mesure que nous avons retrouvé avec le
député Pierre casenu député donc SC qui
accompagné les premières mesures que
nous avons retrouvé dans le PLF je
rappelle que 10 milliards de plus sont
prévus sur la partie transition
écologique énergétique on retrouve un
certain nombre de nos propositions
notamment le fait d'abonder le fond
chaleur de la dem qui est évidemment
quelque chose qui était demandé depuis
un certain temps et puis le déploiement
d'énergie renouvelable où il faut
évidemment accélérer et d'ailleurs
j'encourage tous les élus à s'emparer de
la loi per et notamment du portage qui
qui va être fait par la préfecture des
évelines puisque nous savons jusqu'à la
fin de l'année pour identifier des zones
d'accélération d'énergie renouvelable et
ça c'est très important on revient sur
finalement le début de nos propos la
sobriété mais aussi l'efficacité alors
il y a des étudiants de S qui ont écouté
très attentivement vos propos margaot
est-ce que vous voulez bien venir et
vous allez vous vous poser des questions
Marga c'est à VOUS bonjour mesdames
messieurs merci pour votre intervention
je POS une question question sur comment
est-ce que l'État vous vous accompagne
au niveau local pour réaliser tous ces
travaux de de rénovation notamment la
définition des priorité la préation de
de dossier de candidature pour avoir
accès au fond vous parliez du fond vert
qui nécessite un dossier de candidature
ou même au niveau local de des dotations
comme la
descilement alors de façon très concrète
nous sur ce plan de rénovation des
écoles à Villepreux 3 million d'euros
sur 3 ans on a obtenu cette année des
subventions de la part de la
dotation l'investissement local et le
fond vert également alors les dossiers
sont toujours très longs on l'évoquait
avant le plateau à à monter ce qui
m'amène aussi à un besoin fort que nous
avons nous collectivité en
accompagnement c'est que certes il y a
le besoin en accompagnement financier
mais il y a aussi le besoin
d'accompagner en ingénierie et et ça on
le voit et notamment pour des plus
petites communes même si le département
a un certain nombre d'agences aussi
maintenant je crois que c'est une
véritable nécessité d'être aussi au côté
des communes sur la conception même des
dossiers et notamment l'ingénierie
territoriale qui parfois manque
cruellement il a bien répondu je
rajouterai peut-être quand même que les
collectivités territoriales sont là
aussi pour aider comme le département et
la région selon les
projets de chacun des groupes scolaires
nous allons livrer un groupe scolaire en
janvier prochain ça s'appelle une Cité
de l'enfance c'est une élémentaire
maternel plus une crèche et et du coup
ce projet a remporté l'adhésion et
notamment de la région qui va fortement
nous subventionner on en parlera avec
Valérie tout à l'heure mais c'est vrai
que la région aussi les communes tous
les disposis d'emprunt que je
qualifieraai divhivers finalement que
nous remboursons à des taux très réduits
hein évidemment très intéressant que
nous remboursons au gré en fait du
retour sur investissement qu'on évoqué
tout à l'heure 2è question Josua aussi
étudiant à scienp
Saint-Germain bonjour bonjour à tous et
à toutes merci déjà pour pour votre
intervention euh j'avais une question
concernant les
financements dans un contexte de baisse
de dotation et d'augmentation du coût de
l'énergie est-ce que les les les moyens
qui vous sont attribués pour réaliser
justement cette cette rénovation
sont-ils suffisants la réponse est non
c'est jamais suffisant vous savez euh je
vais vous reprendre les deux chiffres du
début de de ce plateau l'enjeu national
de la rénovation du bâti scolaire 52
milliards d'euros et un fond vert qui va
être abondé cette année à hauteur de de
500 millions alors on prend on va pas se
mentir tout ce qui va dans le sens d'un
accompagnement un peu plus poussé et
prononcé en destination des
collectivités et notamment sur
l'investissement on prend mais je crois
que il va va falloir évidemment que on
soit à la hauteur de l'enjeu et pour le
moment on va dire que le compte n'y est
pas complètement et et les Collectiv les
il n'y a pas de toute façon de de
financement clé en main de choses toutes
faites le très important pour les
collectivités d'identifier les besoins
de prioriser et de faire une ingénierie
financière assez agile et ça va être le
talent des collectivités et et nous avec
eux d'imaginer des des véhicules et des
formes de financement pour justement les
aider parce que finalement il n'y a il y
a des subventions mais elles ne sont pas
suffisantes il y a des financements
privés mais ça ne sera pas suffisant
donc il va falloir imaginer des des des
façons de financer au cas par cas projet
par projet en fonction des objectifs
qu'on se donne pour justement faire
avancer cette transition parce qu'on se
donne un peu 10 ans pour la faire
avancer vraiment il y a un décret
tercière qui qui qui qui invite les
collectivités comme les entreprise a
diminué de moitié les les les
consommations énergétiques des bâtiments
tertières et les écoles font partie des
bâtiments tertièes pour peu qu'ils ont
plus de M qu'ils aient plus de 1000 m²r
mais pour pouvoir le financer il va
falloir au cas par cas établir des
process imaginer des véhicules
travailler sur l'association publique
privée euh et être agile et la politique
des petits pas a toujours été une
politique intéressante aussi et être
agile je pense que c'est effectivement
très important mais je voudrais aussi
rebondir sur l'importance de pouvoir
nous-même dialoguer entre M ou entre élu
parce que les pratiques du quotidien
sont très importantes et pouvoir
échanger certains d'entre nous ont
avancé plus vite que d'autres pour des
raisons diverses et regarder ce qu'il
fait regardez ce qu' se fait à
l'extérieur mais cet échange au sein de
nos territoires elle est absolument
vitale et la mutualisation parce que je
crois que l'avenir aussi sera peut-être
de se dire on a peut-être pas besoin
d'utant de bâtiment et donc demain une
école un préo d'école peut aussi très
bien servir et c'est le cas dans de
nombreuses communes à accueillir des
activités associatives ou autrees donc
ça nécessite c'est ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure de repenser les les usages et
un certain autre fois il y av même les
campagnes politiques qui se faisaient
sous les préau oui oui aussi c'est c'est
pour ça je crois qu'il faut aussi
réimaginer tout ça merci beaucoup josuci
on change merci donc rest reste avec
nous parce qu'on va se quitter
malheureusement je vais remercier Sylvie
Merant il frapp merci beaucoup merci
Jean-Baptiste mercici Pat et merci
beaucoup Sylvie aberd merci
beaucoup